[Music]
in not the father news he's not the
father submitted by Black Betty loves JK
Black Betty a father of nine divorces oh
wait a father of nine divorces his wife
after finding out he had been Cyril for
most of his life changed so much it was
a nine year old father of nine divorces
I thought he had divorced nine times
that's what I thought too he was the
father of nine divorces the way you
phrased it and said it was really
confidence that you had two father of
nine divorces yeah I was like damn I got
divorced nine times yeah no but yeah
father of nine kids is divorcing his
wife because he just found out that he
has been sterile for most of his life so
hard all the kids look different
it's a good question I don't know oh I
don't know if they look different
there's no photos I don't have any
photos oh so all his [ __ ] cheated on
him 1:01 wife oh one [ __ ] I'm still
thinking that there's nine wives
okay got it dan same same wife nine kids
don't know if they all look like or not
they'll be funny it's like already five
it's like the Asian couple and then all
the kids are black and he's like I can't
believe you yeah they were my babies
right here Mullin seven Morocco and so
in Morocco it is elite adultery is
illegal so if they find out that they
all these kids really aren't his the
moms arms off no he's gonna go to jail
why would they do that
how the kids yeah that's so stupid you
know what's even creepier that could
take care of yeah but the dad isn't like
of kids anymore yeah that's what I find
crazy like this wool has raised these
all these kids now that he found out
he's been married for 35 years I don't
know the ages of his kids don't cook but
he is saying that since he found out cuz
he recently went to a urologist and they
says I think there's a cyst on one of
his testicles that he's had there since
as long as he can remember so for about
50 years why has he been going in the
first place
ruined his life Hospital for urologist
welcome
ignorance is bliss they ruin your lives
they tear apart families yeah what if it
mean what if the doctor [ __ ] up and
then he goes oh no business is actually
there yeah so the cyst is there and then
they found out that that cyst has been
blocking like the sperm so making him
sterile and so that's and then so they
did multiple tests and they found out
like yeah this fool has been sterile at
this whole time and so now he's like you
know what I want to divorce my wife and
[ __ ] all these kids I don't want to be
part of the other like them anyway ah I
love you to all your kids every night
you put him to bed I love you it's ego
dude he's just so pissed like obviously
they don't have anything to do with it
groan then they're probably all grown
now right they're like in their 20s or
some [ __ ] dude married for 35 cuz if
they're all grown then [ __ ] them who
cares really though you raise your dad
just found out that you're not his son
and he's like [ __ ] you then it was good
it's a regular Sunday dude what are you
talking about huh
I would get mad at the guy that's the
real father cuz I'll be like
[ __ ] but what if I had these
kids old I slide and taught these kids I
[ __ ] stressed over these kids you
[ __ ] these are your [ __ ] DNA
mother [ __ ] [ __ ] they do arranged
marriages in Morocco nine kids is a lot
that's a [ __ ] yeah let's talk about that
for a second there huh Brady Bunch what
the [ __ ] and it really six though oh my
god I know plus three that's more than
Octomom man it is nine fifteen kid oh I
thought it was eight yeah me too she's
pregnant with eight once that's why
she's an optimum but she already had a
lot of other kids beat up uterus yo did
you see that dude that guy was at the
John and cake guy I heard he went
through some hard times out there huh I
think a bartender's of the head he's
like one of the show coming around
we're yeah now I think the I think the
first two that she had they're going off
to college now or whatever she has a
show coming out where I think they're
it's like a dating show for her a dating
show yeah if she's single
yeah but obviously of course we gotta be
like that's what I'm saying push push
push doubt if she pushed out 13 kids
right obliterated plus eight right says
eight yeah a Jonin capable but a total
but a total at once and then she had
twins first she went first yeah so like
a holy loading if you have like eight
kids come out that [ __ ] did it but if
she did is what I'm saying I'm saying
does it keep getting bigger and bigger
get inflamed just gets easy when they
c-sections her they took out six kids
like did they take them out in a bunch
you can waiter like a waiter picking up
cups you know the way it in the Chinese
way though where they fold up the whole
[ __ ] second like the whole placenta
[ __ ] throat on the bathroom that's a
lot of [ __ ] babies buddy
that's a [ __ ] engine they don't know if
it's from one daddy or like many damn
village yeah yeah I don't know that when
I think of Morocco I think of like
Arabian guys that are like hiding in a
desert and then you're you're in a
caravan trying to like deliver some
goods like silks and [ __ ] and then they
come and raid your [ __ ] with camels yeah
I think of those swords those like
Aladdin types of yeah the curly swords I
didn't have the curly shoes I just think
of dates and honey I think of food yes
riots and honey I think that sigan a lot
of Moroccan dishes and saffron yes a
prawn dance all those
nuts I used to work for this mortgage
company and then the only person that I
knew was Moroccan he was like he's like
I am a Moroccan Jew and I was like
thanks bro
could you speak you some language and
I'm like oh what language is that goes I
am I'm from Morocco but I am Jew well
what's your name man okay that's the
only thing I remember about him oh man
I'm so excited we're gonna be going to
Morocco and Mays and I'm beautiful
for vacation yeah you can ask this lady
hey I was supposed to go to [ __ ]
Europe this year I can't
why because I got too many stupid
[ __ ] weddings to go to you [ __ ] wait
your trip with Mario's canceled oh we're
gonna just we're gonna go island hopping
in Hawaii so we're gonna go to I can't
no we have to we win it no yeah we're
gonna go in between so August 20th to
like ten days after that oh [ __ ] I have
a wedding to good that's what I'm saying
so but at that wedding age that's that
only pocket that we can go so it's like
we could only and all those like tour
packages they don't work within those
[ __ ] days yeah so I couldn't well you
going at August we're going on we have a
wedding in August we do yes wedding yeah
yeah it's the same wedding [ __ ] guy
and then so I it's I am boy so I had to
flight the day
and then we have our Jude and Dan that's
September Oh cuz I was just gonna say I
don't have any friends
cuz I don't know any weddings this no
you those two ways you're going to go to
the August one end of September we have
to go on vacation in between that pocket
I so don't get married guys you [ __ ] up
your friends plenty don't invite them to
these wedding you were invited you
should have been a part of the best
shoes you should have been a part of the
restaurant you left yourself out after
TIFF says something yeah but seriously
though though it kind of did [ __ ] me
because I really wanted to go to Europe
this year and then careful always be
there yeah that's not gonna change
you're the best tour guide ever boys
been changing yeah why there's more
terrorism yeah there's like there's some
more [ __ ] going down there yeah and if
you actually believe that clairvoyant
that said that like in the next ten
years Europe isn't gonna exists or some
[ __ ]
I don't know that clairvoyance know it
she's like super fierce she she's
talking about the New Jersey [ __ ]
medium how does she say it's gonna go
down it's gonna explode or what
no she cuz you know how like when she's
giving her predictions or whatever it's
a really uh yeah very big like all of
them yeah but she supposedly like came
up with or she you predicted 9/11 and
like the bomb Escrima don't go to here
maybe this is saving you destroy no one
ever predicts negative [ __ ] about Hawaii
they never go like that sure terrorist
attack is gonna help talks about Hawaii
is that when you're
they're probably Teddy evacuate the
[ __ ] building cuz I don't know what's
happening they're like oh wait wait my
bed
why do the clairvoyants stay away from
hawaii cuz [ __ ] actually happens they're
like I think one person gets eaten by a
shark a day what this hella tourists
know there's hella tourists and no one
believes them so they always they always
do stupid [ __ ] so there's always like
maybe I throw out the statistic either
even though there's actually a lot of
debt a lot of deaths happened but not
eaten by a shark no I mean like there's
accidents
yes drunk I mean they're so good they're
mandatory I think people maybe they get
they surf they get knocked out on the
reef and the shark like cleans it up
water water water related deaths one a
day okay that's I can't believe I can
wrap my head but all tourist places
there's so many [ __ ] deaths and they
keep it secret like Vegas like I was
reading some [ __ ] about you know Vegas
hotels there's like stories where people
get like the commit suicide or they get
murdered or whatever they have a
cleaning crew come in to make sure that
someone could check in by 3:00 p.m. oh
my god that's gotta be goin down so many
rooms in there I get that but what he
says is this their stolen yeah that's a
business I'll check in right after and
don't have no idea someone just just got
loose we got when we got into our room
it sounds like a crazy pot it is so
imagine the [ __ ] cocaine and
prostitution that was think about the
room the Mandalay big I use you know how
you shot through that through that sweet
right yeah like they're not gonna
[ __ ] not let you rent that you should
make it a tourist attraction might even
be more expensive no I mean like a
museum you see no no don't
on the show on the show like this yeah
like this like kinda hot at the
Holocaust Museum are you something
deeper got you got [ __ ] up man you
want to make money off a [ __ ] tragedy
like money
join otherside cuz I don't want people
do not like me so well how could you say
that that's [ __ ] up the people that
like me love me I love morals shut up
[Music]
[Music]